CHRIS MESSINA: So my
name is Chris Messina.
I work in developer
relations at Google.
I work on the social web team.
And I do a lot of work on web
technologies working on
protocols, formats, and other
things that hopefully are
opening up the web to more and
more interesting applications
and experiences.
The title of my talk today
is the open and social web.
And I'm going to tell you a
little bit of a story that
paints a picture of where
we are with things, and
maybe where we're going.
Before I began, I want
to provide you with a
little bit of context.
First, about me: you can
find me on the web at
buzz.google.com/chrismessina.
And I'm also on Twitter
as Chris Messina.
I tried to trick you with
those usernames, I know.
But I hope we can
figure that out.
Today's hashtag for this
session is #googlesocial.
I also invite you to join us on
Google Wave to discuss this
and other sessions today.
But specifically for
the conversation in
the back channel for this talk
visit j.mp/io-googlesocial.
And one more thing.
Because this is a developer
conference, I know that you
have certain expectations--
very high expectations--
of your speakers.
And I don't want you to be
disappointed when we get to
the end of this talk that
there wasn't enough code.
So I'm presenting you
with fair warning.
If you're looking for a lot of
code, you want to attend my
buddy Joseph Smarr's talk--
who's in the audience here
today-- and John Panzer's talk
this afternoon from 3:00 to
4:00 pm called Bridging the
Islands: Building fluid social
experiences across websites.
That's where you're going
to see all the code.
Now because this is Google I/O,
and because code is an
essential aspect of everything
that we're talking about, I did
want to provide you with a
moment of zen before
we get started.
Without further ado,
please enjoy this moment.
This has to last you for
the next 30, 35 minutes.
And that's about it.
All right.
Enough of that introduction.
I'd like to get actually into
the meat of today's discussion.
Starting off with a little bit
of a prologue to set the scene.
There are going to be a couple
of characters in today's story.
These are our open
web technologists.
And so they reappear throughout
the story, and play a
very, very important role.
In Chapter 1 they introduce
a technology called OpenID
which is a profile and
identity technology.
In Chapter 2, they introduce
something called WebFinger,
which is the technology for
discovering information
about email addresses.
In Chapter 3, we learn about a
whole bunch of new technologies
called PubSubHubbub,
ActivityStreams, and Salmon.
And these technologies are put
together for rich activity and
messaging capabilities
across the open web.
Now these three chapters only
begin to tell the story of
the open and social web
that is emerging today.
The technology that I'm going
to tell you about form the very
early stages of what I hope
will become the foundation of a
much broader, much richer, much
larger social web in
the coming years.
And so we begin.
Once upon a time there was
a character named Kate and
a character named Jack.
Of course Jack lived
on this island.
Kate lived on this
other island.
And one day Jack and Kate,
completely independent of
one another, decided
to go on vacation.
They went from one island to
another and happened as it
was, to meet up at the same
island strangely enough.
This was a much larger
island of course.
But once they arrived, a
curious thing happened.
They ended up meeting one
another and liking each
other considerably.
In fact, they like each other
so much that they fell in love.
Isn't that sweet?
Well not just that, but
they also decided to
yes, get married.
Things move quickly on
this island apparently.
Now there was a problem
as there always is in
such stories as this.
The problem was that their
family and friends couldn't
join them for their wedding.
And this of course made
them very, very sad.
As it happens, when Jack and
Kate were on this island, they
had to leave their family and
friends behind on the islands
where they originally
came from.
Why was this?
As it turned out travel had
gotten increasingly difficult
after Jack and Kate had left.
In fact every time people
visited a new island they were
stopped at the border and
they were turned away.
Or when they arrived they had
to go through a series of steps
that were really frustrating.
Specifically they had to
fill out forms like this.
In fact, every island that they
visited presented them with a
new form to fill out-- some
form of arcane nonsense about
usernames, and maiden names,
and all this nonsense.
It wasn't just that
immigration was really hard.
Every new island that they
visited required them to learn
a secret chant so you can
come back at some later date
and revisit without going
through all these steps.
Well as it turned out of
course, the more islands you
visited, the more of these
secret chants you had to learn.
And there was very little
upside for you to actually keep
track of all this information.
It just became this completely
overwhelming situation where
people couldn't manage all of
these pieces of information in
order to go from one
place to another.
In fact this caused so much
stress that people just
stopped traveling.
However, some of the fat cats
on some of the islands decided
that this was a very
interesting opportunity to
create some business.
So the fat cats got together
and decided that they would
make it possible for their
inhabitants of their islands,
to travel freely from
one island to another.
And this was all well and
fine for the bigger islands.
But of course as you saw on the
map earlier, we're dealing
with an archipelago.
I think that's how
you say that word.
Which of course pissed off
all the little people
on the islands.
They didn't like it
one bit at all.
So they resorted to asking
their friends-- the open web
technologists-- if they
could do anything about it.
Well of course, they were able
to come up with a solution.
And that solution
is called OpenID.
How many of you are
familiar with OpenID?
How many of you use
OpenID on a daily basis?
OK.
There's probably actually
more of you, but that's OK.
For those of you who don't know
what OpenID is, you can kind of
think of it as a skeleton key
for a number of accounts that
you have across the web.
That is you can sign up for an
account on one website, and use
it to sign in our sign
up on another website.
It's actually very convenient.
Now from an adoption
perspective, we're actually
seeing some promising figures.
In fact, as of last summer--
these numbers are a little
bit dated, but I imagine
they've actually improved
considerably since then.
We've seen from next to no
OpenID relying parties-- that
is the websites that consume
OpenID-- to over 50,000 today.
So we've seen a nice growth
curve there in terms of
adoption of this technology.
Another thing that's very
important to understand about
OpenID in the wild, is that the
usage trends themselves reflect
a very interesting and
important aspect of
a decentralized
identity technology.
Namely that people prefer
to use different accounts
in different contexts.
That is, if they have more than
one profile on the web, they
will choose to use a specific
profile in certain contexts.
So one profile provider
may not be sufficient.
For example, on a site called
UserVoice, we see that people
make use of their Google
accounts 34% of time and their
Facebook accounts
33% of the time.
And from there we see other
accounts like Twitter
and Yahoo as well.
On Interscope Records-- which
of course is the home for Lady
Gaga, and Eminem, Lenny
Kravitz, and so on-- we see a
very different type of
statistic where a full 43%,
what is it, 52% of people
choose to use their Facebook
accounts to sign in.
Meanwhile we see a number of
other providers that people
choose to use in this context.
Now most of the Interscope
sites actually promote
heavily the use of Facebook
of Twitter connect.
And yet people still are
choosing to use their other
profiles even despite the user
experience that's been designed
to promote those two providers.
Finally we see something
really different when we
look internationally.
So if you go to a site that
serves essentially as the
eBay of the Philippines.
In this case 64% of their users
are using Yahoo accounts
as their third-party
authentication provider.
So if this site chose to only
support one third-party profile
provider, they would be cutting
off a large number of
their other users.
Which of course would be
very bad for business.
And finally, JanRain, which is
a company that provides a
plugin called RPX that makes it
possible to incorporate
third-party authentication into
websites, sees very interesting
statistics in aggregate across
all that different websites
that use their products.
Specifically 38%, 39% of sites
actually see the usage of
Google profiles and Google
accounts to sign in, second
by Facebook, Yahoo,
Twitter and others.
I think this paints a very
important picture that must
be remembered especially in
the context of the island
nation of the internet.
To learn more about this
technology I invite you
to visit openid.net.
So once again, these open web
technologists had produced this
technology that solved a very
important problem
for islanders.
It made it possible for them to
have a sort of passport that
they could bring with them
wherever they went to these
other islands, which made it
possible for them to visit with
their friends, and their
family, and the people that
were important to them, and yet
still live someplace else.
This of course made both the
fat cats and the island
inhabitants very happy.
Which brings us to Chapter 2.
Once people of course were able
to move freely between islands,
it turned out that they did.
And they decided to relocate.
So you remember
before we have Kate.
And Kate lives on this island.
We have Jack who lives on
this island-- two completely
different islands.
Now what's interesting is that
Kate and Jack's friends used to
be able to send messages or
make phone calls to Kate or
Jack provided they were
on the same island.
Once Kate and Jack left to go
to the new island, it became
increasingly challenging for
their friends and family
to stay in touch.
Because now they couldn't
just say, oh pick up the
phone and call Kate.
Because now they had to specify
Kate at a certain island.
Of course you can imagine how
this solution came about.
Once again our friends the open
web technologists got together
in a room-- probably an open
mailing list of course-- and
decided to develop a new
protocol called WebFinger.
WebFinger is a technology built
on what's called the Hammer
Stack-- named after the creator
of sorts Aaron Hammer-- which
has a bunch of different pieces
of information that allows you
to discover information
about web resources.
So let's take a look
at how that looks.
So imagine you go to a form on
some website, and you want
to find out information
about an email address.
We type the email address into
the box, we click look up.
And what happens is that web
server basically takes the
domain from an email address
and looks in what's called
a well-known location.
So you can see what they've
done is they've taken
that Gmail address, they
split off the username.
They take gmail.com and look
in this specific place:
.well-known/host-meta.
The file that is returned
looks like this.
This provides a way to look up
information about this email
address by looking for
what's called [? the rel ?]
LRDD.
It's essentially a link
resource descriptor.
You now take the email address.
You prepend acct to
turn this into what's
called an account URI.
And you plug that into
this URI template.
OK hopefully this is kind
of making sense so far.
This is essentially how
you find out information
about this email address.
So now we're going to take that
URL that we've constructed,
and we're going to [? curl ?]
against it to find out
what kind of information
the server has.
And you'll note too, that
the WebFinger location is
actually not on gmail.com.
In this case it's
actually on google.com.
So the email provider could
actually point to somebody
else as being the authority
for information about
this email address.
So let's pull that document
back and take a look at it.
What you see here in the
LRDD profile for this
email address, which has a
number of services listed.
Now what this means is that
if I want to perform OpenID
authentication against this
email address, all I
need to do, sorry.
All I need to do is look for
the specific OpenID service
in this discovery document,
which happens to be here.
So if we put this all together
to use WebFinger with OpenID
authentication, this is how the
user experience would work.
We switch from this lookup
activity to a connect activity.
I type my email address
in as I would before.
And this time what happens is
that I'm brought directly to
Google to perform
authentication.
Because in the background the
server has performed WebFinger
lookup, has received that
document with my OpenID service
listed in it, and is now
forwarding me over to
Google to authenticate.
Once I click sign in, I'm
returned back to the place
where I started from, sign
in as Chris Messina.
So in this way, we've actually
used the WebFinger protocol to
discover information about
email addresses in a
distributed, decentralized way.
That in this case, makes
OpenID much easier for
many, many people to use.
We no longer have to rely
on URLs as the primary
key for users.
To learn more about WebFinger,
I invite you to visit this
site: webfinger.info.
So once again, now that the
open web technologists had
developed this technology,
islanders can now keep in touch
with each other regardless
of where they chose to live.
And so they can move about
freely and stay in touch,
because this WebFinger service
provided a sort of fowarding
service to look up information
about their friends and family
who might have moved
to a new place.
Which once again led people
to be very, very happy.
And so they partied all night.
Chapter 3: chapter 3 contains
a lot of information about a
number of emerging
technologies.
In this case, we want to talk
about how people were able to
keep in touch and share with
one another now that they
had moved to new islands.
So in this case, what was very
difficult with all these
islands being distributed, was
that when people wanted to send
messages back and forth to once
another, they essentially had
to go from one place to
another-- back and forth--
constantly checking,
pulling for new messages.
Got anything new?
Anything new for me yet?
How about now?
No, nothing?
OK.
And eventually people got
very frustrated with
this whole process.
It was slow, cumbersome, it was
annoying, it was inefficient.
There were all these
problems with this model.
Furthermore, people started
to actually do more
interesting things.
And they wanted to share richer
and richer media that was no
longer possible to send
over these more minimal
communication channels.
They also wanted to let other
people know about their
activities they were doing all
across all these different
islands as they
explored their new worlds.
And once again, when people
want to share this richer and
richer information, the formats
that they had really just
didn't express the stuff in a
very rich way-- in a way that
also allowed them to send these
messages back to the place
where they needed to go.
So our web technologists
decided to get together and
come up with a series of
technologies that all worked
together to solve these
problems to make it possible to
share rich activity information
with their friends, regardless
of where they lived or what
island they have to be on.
The first of those technologies
is what's called PubSubHubbub.
Which on the one hand may be
an unfortunate name, but the
islanders were very creative
and so that's what
they came up with.
You have a few Mai Tais
too many, whatever.
It all works out.
In this case, the architecture
of PubSubHubbub is
what's interesting.
So in the previous model, you
remember that Kate had to go
back and forth checking for
new messages from Walt.
Well what if Walt could just
post a message and have it
arrive, in real time
essentially, wherever
Kate happened to be.
Well, the solution they came
up with was to involve a
hub in a series of tubes.
So by posting this message
through the series of tubes to
the hub, the hub was able to
deliver this message in real
time to Kate, wherever
she happened to be.
What was also very interesting
about this model is that
it scaled pretty well.
So you could actually have a
number of different subscribers
receiving information
in real time.
Now we've slowed this
down a lot so you can
see how it happens.
But basically the idea is that
the message goes in one, and
then goes through the hub, and
is posted in real time
to the subscribers.
And that's actually all I'm
going to say about that
because it's amazing.
Of course it's one thing to
be able to post messages in
real time from one place to
another using basic formats.
Well, once people started to
do more and more interesting
things on these islands, they
needed a richer way of
expressing information
to their friends.
Their friends could get the
information that was most
valuable to them wherever they
happen to be, in a way that
captured the fidelity
of those activities.
The story of ActivityStreams
actually starts
centuries ago in 1999.
Back in 1999 the world was
a very different place.
People posted information to
websites but were very careful
about other people actually
having access to that
information, or being able to
take it from their websites
because they cared about
something called stickiness.
Stickiness was a concept that
was very important during the
portal era of the web, where
information would be posted
from one place to another
in minimal form.
So for example, you would take
an article like this posted to
let's say the New York Times,
and get this information
into a portal that looks
something like this.
Now the format that expressed
this information was very, very
primitive, very basic-- kind of
like stick figures on rocks.
Essentially the RSS format
specified a very minimal number
of things, of attributes, to
make it possible to take that
information from one
place to another.
Specifically it only really
called for providing a link,
a title, and a description.
Which given a portal model,
was sufficient at that time.
And given how people were
somewhat concerned about their
information leaking from one
place to another, and that
whole stickiness phenomenon,
this is about what people
were able to come up with.
Well let's fast forward
six years to 2005.
In 2005 a new format was
produced called Atom.
Now Atom was a slight
rearticulation of the
ideas expressed in RSS.
And they added some additional
critical attributes.
Specifically an author-- of
course who wrote the piece is
very important-- a unique ID so
that you could identify the
story if it came from multiple
sources, and when it was last
updated, a sort of timestamp so
that you could actually
differentiate between what the
most recent version
of the story was.
But this format was
still predicated on the
notion of providing
information to portals.
Essentially bringing this
information in a very
stripped-down, minimal way to
these places that people would
use as, I guess,
their homepages.
Let's fast forward
to today in 2010.
And we still see this type of
information being produced
largely in this format.
Which makes a whole
lot of sense.
However in the last decade, the
best experience that we have in
today's modern browsers for
consuming that information,
looks something like this.
And if you think about the
portals used to look, versus
how modern browsers present
this information, not a
whole lot has changed.
And so as the social web has
evolved, we're still relying
on the same basic format for
expressing this information
and syndicating it from
one place to another.
When it comes to machines
helping us to filter this
information and figure out what
the most relevant bits are, how
are they supposed to
differentiate if all
of it looks the same?
And yet we know that people are
actually engaging in richer
and richer and more diverse
activities across the web--
even across the same websites.
They're doing different
types of activities.
Well all this is the back story
for the ActivityStreams format.
What we've essentially done is
we've taken that basic format
for RSS and Atom of author,
title, and link, as the sort of
primitive structures for this
information, and we've changed
it just slightly to express
information in an author, verb,
object archetype, with
an optional target.
For example, when you're
posting photos to a
photo album or posting
something to a wish list.
The other thing that we've done
is we've taken the Atom
format-- which again only
specifies these six attributes
as being very important-- and
we've layered in a verb, an
object-type, and
again a target.
We've actually reused the
author element as the actor.
So what's nice is that if
you're already producing an
Atom feed of content on your
website, upgrading to produce
the AcitivityStreams format
is actually rather simple.
In fact, this is an example
of Atom and ActivityStreams
woven together.
The important pieces here
to notice are these.
This basic additional
information allows a consumer
of ActivityStreams to identify
a person that posted a note.
Now that seems very simple
and very primitive.
I mean, this is the same
essential information
that we had before.
Except that we can use that
structure and those three
pieces of information to
encompass a whole lot of
different types of activities.
For example, if a person
shared a link, or if somebody
started following somebody
else-- maybe even you.
But this need not be
just about people.
It can also be used for
services, for example,
to update their status.
So these primitive structures
can actually do a whole lot
to help people find out
what's going on across the
distributed social web.
Now there's another nice
feature here which I think is
very important to point out.
In the earlier days of
RSS and Atom, and
increasingly now as all this
information and all our friends
are starting to produce more
and more information, we're
left with kind of an
information glut.
On the one hand, people call
this information overload.
But I would call it
information abundance.
It's as though we have
this massive coal.
And yet we haven't figured out
how to actually refine it yet
to do more interesting things.
And so of course on the one
hand, this information
abundance comes in and pummels
us over the head to the point
where you know we just can't
deal with it anymore.
And this is the whole idea
of information overload.
It's just stressful.
What are we supposed to do
with all of this information?
ActivityStreams, in contrast,
makes it possible to actually
filter this information based
on that actor, verb, object
model so that we're getting the
information that we need, when
we need it, from the people
that we most care about.
The third technology that
I want to talk to you
about is bleeding edge.
It's not even final yet.
In fact, you'll hear more about
it this afternoon from John
Panzer and Joseph Smarr.
And it's a technology
called Salmon.
Now when I talked to you about
PubSubHubbub previously, one of
the interesting aspects of this
model was that the information
flowed from one place-- in this
case Walt to Kate-- in
a unidirectional way.
That is it flowed from one
place to another without
necessarily providing a
way to respond back.
So if Kate wanted to actually
respond, it's not clear
how she would do that.
So Salmon provides a mechanism
to actually respond to these
activities in real time using a
push mechanism that looks
a little bit like this.
So essentially she writes
something, a little
Salmon comes along.
And because Salmon have
actually very good senses of
smell, they're able to find
their way back to the original
poster source in a way that's
actually secure and fast.
The other nice feature of
Salmon is that it works for
mentioning people across
different islands.
So in this case, let's say that
Kate posts a message that
she wants to share
with her friends.
But her friends happen to
be on different islands.
The messages arrive at
the proper place because
they've been addressed
to people elsewhere.
So in this case, this
goes back to Jack on the
island of clickset.com.
And in this case, John receives
the message on the island
of the [? Atolia. ?]
So by posting these messages in
a certain way using
WebFinger-based identifiers--
again essentially email
addresses-- we're able to send
these messages back without
relying on the email
infrastructure.
So this works over HTTP by
just posting information
back to Salmon endpoints.
I'm not going to tell you more
about this now because Joseph
and John have to have something
to talk about this afternoon.
But I do invite you to learn
more about these technologies
at j.mp/pubsubhubbub,
activitystea.ms, and
salmon-protocol.org.
Combining these technologies,
the open web technologists
essentially were able to
provide a mechanism for people
distributed across all these
different islands to stay in
touch in a rich way, and to
communicate in real time, and
to respond back regardless of
where they happened to live.
Which of course, once again,
made everybody extremely
happy this time.
And so they all lived,
at least in this case,
happily ever after.
Now, no story is complete
without an epic-log.
And so in chapter 1 we learned
about OpenID and identity and
profile technology which is
currently actually being revved
in a very important way.
But this technology allowed
for islanders to essentially
identify each other as they
traversed the known waters of
the island of space,
or something.
In chapter 2, we learned about
WebFinger-- a way for learning
more about email addresses
which are more familiar to
people as a way of representing
who they are as they
communicate with one another.
And as we just heard about in
chapter 3, ActivityStreams,
Salmon, and PubSubHubbub
provide the mechanism for
people to stay in touch
regardless of where they went.
Now all of this provides a
useful backdrop for Google and
the social web, and where
Google wants to see
the social web go.
Of course I'm using this island
metaphor to illustrate where we
are with the web today, and
where I think the web should
move to to enable cross-site
social networking
activities to occur.
By leveraging a number of
emerging technologies, we're
starting to see the emergence
of a social web that is
actually the entire scale and
scope of the web itself, as
opposed to being restricted to
any one particular island.
And for us that ability to have
choice among which islands you
tend to spend your time
in is fundamental.
In fact these technologies
are forming the foundation
for the Buzz platform.
DeWitt Clinton, who is one of
my co-workers, actually wrote
in a Buzz that the idea behind
Buzz is that some day any host
on the web should be able to
implement these open protocols
and technologies without any
one company in the middle.
And that specifically, Google
Buzz itself, would just be
another node, a very good one
we hope of course,
among many peers.
And by stringing all these
things together and promoting
the technologies that power and
open in social web, we hope to
make the entire web experience
much better for many, many more
people for years and
decades to come.
So with that I'd
like to conclude.
Of course I'd also like to
thank Jack and Kate for their
participation in this talk.
And I'd also like to remind you
to check out the back channel
discussion on Google Wave:
j.mp/io-googlesocial.
And-- a couple more
advertisements for you: I'd
like to invite you to check
out What's the hubbub
about Google Buzz APIs?
presented at 1:45, next in
room 8 by Chris Chabot.
Later on again this afternoon
from 3:00 to 4:00 pm: Bridging
the Islands which will be the
code-centric version of this
talk, I hope, presented
by Joseph and John.
And finally tomorrow-- this is
not today, this is tomorrow-- a
fireside chat with the social
web team from Google from
2:15 to 3:15 in the
Fireside Chat Room.
And so that's all I have.
And so I open the floor for
questions and answers.
One request that I have-- well
let's make it two-- is that if
you do have a question, you
come up to the mic, and that
your question begins with a
capital letter and ends
in a question mark.
Otherwise we're good.
All right thank you very
much your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS MESSINA: Questions, yes?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Have you given much thought to
like long-term data retention
for all of this social
media activity?
So one thing that comes to mind
for me is the Library of
Congress deal with Twitter.
It's going to live forever.
Have you thought about maybe
a time [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
expirations on any of this data
so it's not out there forever?
CHRIS MESSINA: So the question
is about data retention.
And of course, data retention
has a lot of different
ramifications to it.
What I would say, is that the
thing that I'm most interested
in with a lot of these
technologies and protocols, is
first of all making it possible
for this data to flow
between different places.
When it comes to the retention
of this information I feel like
that's both a provider specific
implementation point, as well
as an individual choice
aspect of this.
So whether you'd prefer for
your data to be captured, and
sequestered, and stored, for
eons or for five minutes, it
should be possible using
these technologies.
So the technologies themselves
and these protocols don't
necessarily need to I think,
provide a policy for that.
But I do hope that the choice,
increasing the number of
choices on the social web would
enable people to have the
ability to pick a provider
that meets their needs.
Does that make sense?
OK?
Other questions?
No?
All right well, you guys
are free to go then.
Thank you very much.
Oh, sorry one more question.
AUDIENCE: In the story that you
told, there are two people.
As a person, I have
multiple personalities.
I'm walking out of my place
and I'm a member of some
sort of social club.
And I have multiple ideas.
Sometime I'd like to connect
multiple things to different
ideas so you can choose one.
CHRIS MESSINA: So you're
talking about personas.
So one thing that's very
important to me, and I think to
a lot of people who work on
these protocols and
technologies, doesn't on the
one hand go back to the ability
to have choice in the
providers that you use.
The second piece, which I think
answers your question in some
ways, is that identity in
particular is a very
complex issues.
So providing people with the
means to express different
facets of their identity in
different contexts, I think
is extremely important.
However one of the challenges
that we have with a lot of
the emerging social web
technologies, is first of all
to make it easy enough for many
more people to implement and
adopt these technologies that
first allow for federated
identity to work on the web.
And then secondly, to provide
for these more expressive
mechanisms that allow you
to actually segment your
profile if you choose to.
AUDIENCE: Or if I have
multiple profiles?
CHRIS MESSINA: Or if you have
multiple profiles, precisely.
Because we don't have that
basic fundamental layer yet
expressed either in the web
itself or in web browsers, it's
very hard to even approximate
the type of feature that
you are requesting.
However once again, nothing in
these technologies prohibits
or inhibits that possibility
from existing in the future.
So ideally with getting more
people involved in these things
we can actually see those type
of use cases developed more
and played out more fully.
OK another question?
SPEAKER: Chris you
have a bit more time.
There are a lot of questions
in Wave in the moderator.
I don't know if you're able
to pull that up up there.
You should be able to.
CHRIS MESSINA: I don't know.
I turned off the internet
on my computer.
Does somebody want to tell me
the questions on moderator?
Please.
OK.
So the question is about who
owns the contents that gets
aggregated and syndicated
I suppose, into all
these applications.
And that also is a
very tricky question.
And one that I don't know that
we have either the policy or
the technological means
to address completely.
Part of it is because social
data itself is inherently a new
type of intellectual asset
that I don't quite know how
it's going to play out.
So for example, if I post a
photo on the social web and you
download that photo to your
hard drive, should I have the
right to delete that photo
off of your hard drive.
Well this is an expectation
that some people actually have.
On the other hand, the
person that downloaded that
photo would think very
differently about it.
Now we've adapted our
expectations, for
example, of email.
Such that when we send and
email to somebody else, we
don't necessarily expect to
be able to take it back,
especially if that
information goes from one
server to another.
We might be able to even
develop the technical means
to make it possible to
retract those emails.
But that creates a different
type of social expectation and
a different type of social
contract then people
currently expect.
And so while we can do
many, many things from a
technological perspective,
there's still a lot of
behavioral things that need to
be worked out between people
and between what their
expectations are to answer
those questions fully.
Unfortunately or fortunately,
we're spending a lot more time
again just making it possible
for the data to flow in the
first place, and then hope that
people will be able to work out
the different policy mechanisms
that'll be enforced through
other means once the
technology is there.
Other questions?
SPEAKER: I can read the top few
off moderator if you want.
CHRIS MESSINA: Mhmm.
SPEAKER: How do you see
Buzz competing with
Facebook or Twitter?
CHRIS MESSINA:
Very well I hope.
Yeah I think you know, one of
the goals again with Buzz, is
for there to be a much broader
set of people supporting
these technologies.
And in fact, we've been working
through the communities Twitter
and Facebook to make it
possible for whether it's
ActivityStreams, or
authentication information,
profiles, to be able to become
much more interoperable.
We're at the very, very early
stage in the development
of social web.
And I think hopefully this
competition will actually force
everybody to focus on the user,
and provide better experiences
through these emerging
technologies.
SPEAKER: So social streams
looks like the syntax, or
those kinds of interchanges.
How are people thinking about
managing the semantics, like
what types of messages,
activities, etc.?
CHRIS MESSINA: Right.
So when it comes to developing
ActivityStreams, and
specifically the schema I'll
say, what we've done so far
through the community, is we've
actually done a great deal of
research borrowing from my
microformats process.
Namely we've gone out across
the social web and we've looked
for existing examples of
activities that are being
produced by social websites
and we've extracted
common patterns.
From those common patterns,
we've come up with a list of 40
verbs and object types that
Buzz currently supports as a
subset, but that we hope to see
many more providers
start to produce.
Over time, because we've
made it possible for the
extensibility model of
ActivityStreams to
support URI-based verbs
and object-types.
You could essentially develop
your own set of verbs and
object-types that you use
to interoperate with
different providers.
So I think this creates a very
good foundation for people to
do interop between
different places.
But we're starting by looking
at what's already in the wild
as opposed to inventing things
that don't already exist.
Does that answer you question?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: User facing privacy
controls have seemed to
be very challenging.
On the one hand you have
Facebook which has this
incredibly complex tree.
On the other hand Buzz faced
some challenges early on.
Now you have locked down almost
completely, which is good.
Are you working on a better
version for simplified user
facing privacy controls
that are also effective?
CHRIS MESSINA: This is one of
the questions that keeps me up
at night in a lot of respects.
As you notice, there's not
a lot of code in his talk.
That's because my background is
actually as a designer and as
a user experience creator.
And as a result of that, I've
been watching very carefully
not only all the privacy
interfaces that of course are
being developed, but also
trying to understand how to
communicate to people different
social contexts and
environments, and who was able
to see the things that they
publish and produce, and what
their expectations are.
This is an extremely
large challenge.
Because from interface
perspective you want to
of course, get out of
the way of the user.
But from a user perspective, if
things don't work out the way
you expect them to, then
your trust gets erroded.
And so we haven't quite found
the right balance between
making it very easy for people
to express their privacy and
publicity desires with an
interface that get
out of their way.
That said, we've done a lot
of research and I think are
developing a number of new
interfaces and interactions
to help with that.
I personally have been
doing work through the
OpenID foundation.
And I'll be doing much more of
that this summer to develop a
series of user interaction
guidelines that might
help with that respect.
But we don't have a great
story necessarily today.
AUDIENCE: Do you know of any
good examples of things that
you think might be-- for
example, good examples
of sites that do this
really, really well?
CHRIS MESSINA: So the question
is about whether or not there
are examples of sites that do
this type of thing very well.
One of the things that I do is
I take a lot of screenshots
of web interfaces.
I invite you to check out
flickr.com/factoryjoe to see
some of these interfaces.
But I do think that for
example, a service called
brightkite does a pretty good
job of some of these things.
I think that the Buzz interface
is actually not a bad start.
I think that even some of the
things that Facebook does are
very innovative and
very interesting.
Though of course, trying to
work to create perhaps more of
an industry standard for
expressing this information to
people is something that
still needs to be done.
So other than that, I don't
have great examples yet.
SPEAKER 1: So the next one is
an adoption question around
federation, like some of the
stuff you talked about.
What will it take for data
replication to stop, and a
peer to peer distributed
singular data set as
the social framework?
CHRIS MESSINA: Can
you repeat that?
SPEAKER 1: What is it going to
take to make the federation
actually happen, is
the spirit of it.
CHRIS MESSINA: One of the
things that I'll tell you about
that I think is actually very
interesting and very exciting,
just came out this past Friday.
David Recordon, one of the
original architects and authors
of OpenID, wrote a proposal
that pulls together a number of
different ideas and concepts
that have been floating around
the community for some time,
and put it into a proposal
called OpenID Connect.
So if you visit
openidconnect.com you can
find out information
about this emerging idea.
Essentially to answer your
question, one of things that
we've run into as a challenge
in terms of getting these
technologies adopted, is
providing the right level of
benefit to publishers
as well as to users.
So OpenID is a technology
that largely came out of a
security and privacy centric
community of people.
And then the challenge that
we've seen in the last several
years, with the development of
other connect style APIs, is
that single sign on alone, is
not sufficient to provide
publisher value.
So we're re-working parts of
OpenID to make it possible to
not only identify someone who
chooses to log in with a
certain profile, but also to
get access to the data that
they choose to share.
So combining OAuth 2.0 and
OpenID together, the hope is
that we can actually provide
enough publisher value while
still preserving the original,
both decentralization and
privacy centric aspects of
OpenID to get wider
spread adoption.
So a number of things from the
user experience to publisher
value to the complexity of the
technology, and they we're
finally going back to the
drawing board in some of these
things and making some solid
progress actually to get better
adoption of these technologies
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
I have two questions.
One, I was wondering if you
could comment on the current
speed with which tweets are
being brought into Buzz.
Because I know they happen
really quickly on a Google
search but on Buzz sometimes
it's hours and hours.
And the second, I was wondering
if you could give me your
opinion on the current Facebook
privacy issues in context of
the Buzz launch and sort of the
hubbub that happened there.
CHRIS MESSINA: Those
are tough questions.
The first question is about
speed in which tweets are
being brought into Buzz.
And unfortunately I'm not
the authority for that.
So I can't speak to that.
The second question is about
Facebook, and privacy, and
the Buzz launch, and so on.
The thing that I would say
about that is that first
of all, there's a lot of
improvements that have been
made to Buzz since it launched.
I think that we've learned a
great deal in that process.
I'm not specifically on
the Buzz product team.
Though I know that there are
countless conversations and
debates that have gone on to
improve the product, and to
make it more responsive to
peoples' expectations.
As I said in my previous
answer, this is a
very wide open area.
And one that deserves not only
a great deal of study, but also
I think the involvement of
a lot more disciplines to
understand what's going on.
So i'm personally watching all
these things very closely,
both as a designer and
as a technologist.
And I think we're going to
start seeing a lot more of
these ideas actually being
built into the Buzz
platform itself.
From a technology perspective
though, we're trying to make
sure that we can be generative
and expressive in how people
manifest these things so that
these technologies work in both
very public environments as
well as places where people
have greater expectations
of privacy or control.
So I can't provide a more
specific answer than that,
but that's how I would
address that question.
Any other questions
or comments?
All right well you've
been a great audience.
Thanks very much.